uh speak um
in a bigoted way about people um or um
or that were too salacious
that sort of thing
so
there are other letters for somebody
else to uh publish
so i leave that to somebody else so
anything else
well this was great i'm glad that you
came and heard me talk and
thanks again for the opportunity to talk
to you
thank you
[Applause]
gerard walt is a curator of the papers
of presidential families in the
manuscript division of the library of
congress visit their website at loc.gov
william bulger was a boston politician
who became president of the
massachusetts state senate and later was
appointed president of the university of
massachusetts his brother james bulger
ran an organized crime operation in
south boston and remains on the fbi's
most wanted list
radio talk show host howie card tells
their story in the brothers bulger
he spoke about it at jabberwocky
bookshop in newburyport massachusetts
for about an hour
[Laughter]
i don't doubt it
welcome to jabberwocky bookshop i'm
events director kelly horan jones and
it's my great pleasure to welcome you
here for an evening
with howie carr
celebrated columnist
radio talk show host
journalist and author howie carr
has built his career on courage
he asks the tough questions and he
demands straight answers
he's also the father of five daughters
so i think we know where he gets his
practice
with the brothers bulger howie carr has
given us a stunning expose and a
riveting true crime tale
of how corruption wound its way up from
boston's seedy criminal underbelly
to the city's elite ranks
courtesy of a pair of notorious siblings
working both ends of the spectrum
please join me in welcoming an author
that the mob might rather we're swimming
with the fishes but we're so glad he's
here with us tonight
ladies and gentlemen howie carr
thanks a lot everybody
we have c-span here tonight so i got to
keep this sign up
very glad to be here i'll be uh i got a
lot of magnets here for everybody that
i'll be passing out
i'll i'll sign anything you've got
except a basketball
[Laughter]
for those of you who aren't familiar
with the story there's a uh there's a
guy out it's gonna be on 60 minutes
tomorrow night uh he he's he says that
they were they were going to kill me at
uh
as i came out of my house in uh in acton
and uh they first they were going to
what they said they were going to put a
a basketball
full of c4 plastic explosives you know
dynamite's not good enough for them you
know that's just that's just too
commonplace it's too easy to get we'll
get some of that james bond stuff
and that's what whitey wanted to do and
you know a basketball i i don't know
what that's all about is most of you who
listen to my radio show and though they
would have a
better chance of getting me to pick up
something if it
they put some c4 and i don't know some
some donuts or some fried clams or
something a basketball
and then they were gonna then they were
gonna pick me off from the this uh
graveyard across the street
and you know i just haven't been taking
it very seriously i talked to a pr guy
today who's a friend of mine and he said
you know howie maybe you know you should
have been less dismissive you know you
know saying he didn't have the stones to
shoot me you know that makes you seem
like you're a street guy too you know
why didn't you you know talk about the
first amendment you know how what a
courageous journalist you were and all
that
but the thing is i've been hearing this
guy tell this story for uh for 10 years
now you know his
a close personal relative of his lives
around the corner from where i lived
it's not like they had to do any
investigating they knew where they you
know the guy probably his his relative
probably just pointed out the house and
said that's where howie lives and it
slowly be and you know the way it is
with you know you go to high school or
college with somebody they barely make
the football team or the basketball team
and they're they're scrubs bench warmers
five years later you run into them at a
party and they're talking about how they
started right
ten years later they were all conference
it's the same thing this guy was the
gravedigger and now he's promoted
himself up to being a hitman
so i wrote that at my column on thursday
afternoon you know that he was promoting
himself from gravedigger to hitman i go
home and i'm looking on the internet to
see how the story is playing on the on
the wires and it says hitman hired to
kill columnist i said it worked you know
in the military they give you
battlefield promotions this guy gave
himself a graveyard promotion
but i'm glad to be here tonight and to
talk about the the bulgers and uh you
know we we all know
who who they are these they're these two
brothers there's uh whitey jimmy bulger
the uh the the hoodlum the cocaine
dealer the serial killer and then
there's his his brother the president of
the massachusetts state senate at one
time the president of the university of
massachusetts
also known as the corrupt [ __ ]
people say howie did you invent that
name i say no was invented by a judge
whose uh court he basically destroyed he
invented the name but
i picked it up and ran with it
the cm
and you know the thing is i'm gonna i
want to just throw it open to questions
mostly but i'll just do the the quick uh
chronology here of the of the two
brothers the uh
whitey bulger was a a career criminal
there's a there's a good story i think
in my book about
his one of his early uh adventures in
crime he was he uh
billy bulger the future president of the
senate and will mcdonough you remember
him he was the boston globe sports
columnist and the nfl analyst
will mcdonough was a also from south
boston and uh so they they're they're
about 12 years old or so something like
that 12 13 years old they're coming back
from the beach on a uh on a summer day
and uh all of a sudden
whitey pulls up in a cadillac
convertible cadillac he's wearing no
shirt they've never seen the cadillac
before
and
so
whitey says get in
and even then they knew better than to
refuse an invitation he was making him
an offer they couldn't refuse
so uh billy and will you jump into the
cadillac and they don't know where it's
coming from and whitey's just driving
along you know shirtless just kind of
whistling and enjoying the sights and
then they come to one of those all
there's this kid peddling one of those
old ice cream trucks you know
the the freezer is built onto the onto
the bike and and uh i guess billy billy
leans forward and says to to whitey
that's o'leary i never liked that kid
o'leary and white he goes really
so he pulls the car in right behind
the bike
and he taps the bike
and the kid of course immediately
freaks out goes crazy and starts
pedaling furiously trying to get away
and whitey laughs pulls the car up again
closer to him the cadillac taps the kid
again and he's just now he's really out
of control because he thinks he's about
to be run over by the big car so he's
going faster and faster and so billy
leans forward and says
jimmy i said i didn't like him i didn't
tell you to kill him
and whitey laughed and said
i'm not going to kill him
the bus is gonna kill him when he goes
through broadway
without stopping
so even even at an early age why do you
like to to have other people do his
dirty work for him
and i i think
he he was the he was the guy after he he
wasn't released from prison until 1965
as you know if you've read the book he
took part in the lsd experiments in
atlanta that was sponsored at the
atlanta penitentiary that was sponsored
by the cia
and uh he wrote a lot about that i put a
lot of the the uh
the writings that he did in his in his
final months in boston he was i think he
was trying to set himself up as some
kind of victim
as you know as
of a a government program run amok kind
of like a white tuskegee project you
know
and uh so he blamed that for his
problems then then he got transferred to
alcatraz and he was spent three years
there met one of the loves of his life a
guy named the choctaw kid whose funeral
he later paid for when he died of aids
and then he went to leavenworth and then
he got out in 1965 when he got out in 65
his brother billy was just a
freshman state rep and
it was not a freshman i guess a second
term a second or third term but he was a
back bencher and but as soon as as soon
as whitey was out on the street and he
was at the lowest rungs of organized
crime at the time he was just a muscle
guy for for some fading top dog in
southie and billy's just the back
bencher but they immediately began
rising to the top
and it all had to do with the fbi the
the fbi the federal government promoted
them and how many people here remember
john j mccormick
yeah i do too we're the old-timers in
the audience
the kids are going who
he was the speaker of the u.s house of
representatives he was from south boston
and after jfk was shot in 1963 he was
one heartbeat away from the presidency
if anything if if lbj had had a heart
attack he would have become president of
the united states
and this was a guy who took care of the
bulgers the bulgers were his
constituents again
you go back to the early part of my book
i got the the documents about the
from whitey's uh
military career
and i know this will surprise a lot of
you but whitey was a disciplinary
problem
in the air force
and they were they were they they were
having disciplinary hearings it was one
step below a court martial
and
so i got the i got the actual not the
transcripts but the description of the
the hearing and at one point he says he
says you better not do anything to me or
i'll call my congressman john mccormick
and
j so that's israel that's 1952. they're
they're uh and of course john mccormick
had a brother named naco
great name right naco mccormick
how southy is it
knocko was the biggest bookie in town he
had a big bar in andrew square and every
st patrick's day he'd ride the uh he
ride his horse had to be a big horse too
like a clydesdale because he weighed
about 400 pounds
he'd ride it through there
anyway mccormick in 1968
he does another favor for the bulger
family they're one of their neighbors a
guy named john connolly
john
zip
connolly
wants to get on the fbi
and do you know who
writes that first letter
to get zip connelly onto the fbi who
wrote the letter to j edgar hoover
john mccormick the speaker of the house
and for those of you who aren't familiar
with where zip is now
this is my magnet
this is him in an orange in an orange
jumpsuit he'll be standing trial in
florida next month on first degree
murder charges involving one of the gang
land hits
now
once they get once they get the connolly
into the fbi and then they got him back
to boston and he he's just taking care
of business with the with the bulgers
pretty soon he's taken he's taken money
from uh from whitey
and oh by the way another thing is
another favor that the fbi does for
whitey 1971 again he's not he hasn't
moved that far up in the ranks of the uh
of organized crime but all of a sudden j
edgar hoover of all people j edgar
hoover
sends a memo to the boston office of the
fbi ordering them to recruit whitey as
an informant
again it was probably a favor for
mccormick because mccormick uh even
though he had retired as speaker by then
he probably knew that the
this this was what was this this was the
way to protect whitey
so anyway you i i can run over the rest
of the story pretty pretty quickly you
know what happened uh at this point uh
whitey
wipes out his competition in south
boston joins the winter hill gang from
somerville
they get involved in in race fixing
everybody's about to be indicted and all
of a sudden at the last minute thanks to
the uh
intervention of zip connolly and another
couple of fbi agents in some u.s and
some people in the u.s attorney's office
whitey and his partner steve flemmi are
cut out of the indictment so that
basically all of their
colleagues in the so-called irish mafia
although it's irish and italian both are
taken off the board
next
billy bulger
he's he his path to the senate
presidency is blocked by two guys one of
whom is from this area
kevin harrington from salem is the salem
this area considered this area yeah
right yeah and then the other guy is uh
joe dicarlo who is uh at the same age as
him another guy from suffolk county
revere and what happens
not not that these guys were
particularly innocent but uh the fbi
after a very fitful investigation sends
uh zip connolly out to get info they
indict
joe dicarlo he's convicted he files an
appeal that brings down harrington and
all of a sudden
billy bulger is the president of the
senate
and guess what the two lawyers the two
lawyers for the uh for the two senators
the carlow and the republican bag man
mackenzie
they didn't do a very good job how are
they rewarded
judgeships there's someone who's read
read the book right
right yeah you remember yeah
yeah i talked to the uh i talked to me
joe dicarlo didn't want to talk to me
when i was
doing the book but i talked to some of
his friends and family members and they
said they thought of doing their own
book
and they only they'd only gotten as far
as a title
you know what the title was
it's worse than you
think i said that's a good title now
you're going to get to work on the rest
of the black
so then
then at this point
billy is the president of the senate
and but whitey still has to worry about
the mafia
so what do they do
paging zip connelly paging zip connolly
let's take the mafia off the board for
the for the bulgers so they uh they they
put they put whitey in as a uh as one of
the informants for the search warrant if
you're if you're on that title three
it's called you're not going to be
prosecuted even though
you know your your name turns up in
criminal wrongdoing on the wiretaps
because it would open the open the
grounds to an appeal
so whitey whitey has the mafia taken off
the board and all of a sudden he's on
top
of the whole
the whole rockets world in boston
and at this point billy's on top in
politics whitey's on top in organized
crime
and
suddenly
people who cross whitey
who work in state government
start to suffer consequences serious
consequences there was lieutenant
colonel of the state police jack
o'donovan he put a bug in a garage on
lancaster street in the west end of
boston where whitey was hanging out
why he didn't care for that the next
budget
an anonymous outside writer is attached
to the senate budget
that would have forced the requirement
of
lieutenant colonel jack o'donovan
and you know who vetoed it ed king he
gets such a bad rap as a as the uh when
he was the governor but he's he was the
lat until mitt romney he was the last
governor to tell
tell billy bulger no
you know the story of the state trooper
i think he's a guy from essex essex
county he's deceased now billy johnson
he he was a state trooper at logan
airport you know that's the that's the
plush assignment
f troop
and uh
he was at the international terminal one
day and uh whitey comes through with a
bag of cash he's taken it to montreal he
was even then he was planning his his
escape
his his flight
and uh
trooper johnson stops him from going
through when the when the cash shows up
on the uh
on
at the uh security gate in the x-ray
and uh he and uh he and whitey are going
at it
and whitey gets rid of the cash and
the next day mike dukakis governor
dukakis nominee
for the guy who runs logan airport for
him show shows up at the barracks at
logan airport and demands the police
report billy johnson refuses to give it
to him he's out
he's sent to a less desirable location
he had a he had a guy named johnny
powers the former senate president from
south boston
i don't i'm not going to ask anybody to
raise their hands if they remember
johnny powers
see at the dog track
he's been gone a long time but he he ran
the courthouse uh patronage operation
the courthouse payroll whitey had a
no-show job at the courthouse there are
questions who got him the job whether it
was will mcdonough or billy bulger will
mcdonough claim the credit for it
johnny powers finally said i can't have
this guy on the payroll even if it's a
no-show job these guys have the keys to
the district attorney's office
so he fired whitey
after billy became the senate president
what happened to johnny powers
his pay was frozen for five years his
aids pay was frozen for five years
and of course billy denied that he had
anything to do with this the the he he
couldn't remember anything about it the
only way he ever found out about it was
he he read about it in the newspapers
even give you another example before i
throw it open to questions uh the mass
convention center authority people
people really seem to be surprised when
i talk about the mass convention center
authority even though i've written
written about it for for years it seems
like the mass convention center
authority was set up basically to uh
originally to to enable boston to
to get some money to settle some
abatement lawsuits and that kind of
stuff and deal with prop two and a half
and this the state got this new quasi
public authority as it's called and
built the heinz convention center
on boylston street that was a great
investment by the way
after they paid off the bonds they spent
450 million dollars on the heinz
convention center authority the new
treasurer tim cahill
ordered an assessment of it when he got
into office
remember 450 million was spent
you know what it's worth
35 million
boy that's taking advantage of the real
estate boom in massachusetts huh
so the first guy that gets hired is uh
as the executive director of the mass
convention center authority is uh
francis xavier joyce
what's his claim to fame
he's the ten whistle player in billy
bulger's band
the irish
volunteers he becomes the the he becomes
the chairman
the executive director a lifetime
appointment
one of his first hires
a woman named nancy stanley who was
nancy stanley's mother
teresa stanley
whitey's girlfriend
another one of the early appointments
lisa matarano
is that name ring a bell
her her father is johnny madorano the
hitman
for whitey
she immediately gets bagged for uh
embezzling at twenty one thousand
dollars and they send in her her uncle
jimmy matarano to negotiate the uh
settlement with a with a former fbi
agent who's a friend another friend of
the bulger family
named bob sheehan
bob sheehan is the fbi agent who offered
another gangster
named hugh shields who whitey had shot
at one point but i digress
sheehan offers
shields the gangster the keys to the
angelo's mafia headquarters in the north
end and a machine gun to take him out
and for his fine performance in
the pursuit of law and order sheehan
gets a job at the mcca and he settles up
the moderato thing they got it they they
own the undercommon garage the new mass
convention center authority who's one of
the first people that gets hired or gets
kept on there a guy named eddie goss
eddie goss happens to be one of the
original criminal partners
of uh stevie flemy who was whitey's
underworld partner he too went to the
can by the way for stealing money
you hire people from organized crime and
they steal money go figure
so
this is what's been this is what has
been going on for a long time and you
know people people say well how did they
get away with it how come nobody wrote
about this for all these years
and this gets back to the to the
headlines of the last few days
involving me
there was a guy named paul corsetti
worked for the boston herald and he was
he was a tough guy he was from medford
he was a second generation police
reporter and
he was a vietnam vet drove a truck over
there
not no shrinking violet he was working
on a story once 1980 about a murder
white he had killed a guy named louis
littiff who was doing freelance hits so
he had to go
so they he went
and they they dumped him off over in the
south end there uh larry zanino's
laundromat i don't know if it was a
message to the mafia or what or just
that was just a nice place to drop him
but anyway
corsetti starts working on the story and
he gets a call
from some guy who gives him some
tantalizing hints and says you want to
find out some more about the lit of hit
meet me down in quincy market at one of
the bars
so paul says okay i'll go down there so
he goes down there and he's
he's sitting on the bar stool waiting
for this whoever to show up he doesn't
know the guy's name so this uh you know
this average-sized middle-aged guy
sidles up next to him in the stool and
says hey aren't you paul corsetti starts
making small talk with him
paul plays along for a while
and uh then he finally says i you know
i'd like to keep talking to you but i'm
waiting for somebody
the guy looks at him and says
you're waiting for me mother bleeper i'm
jimmy bulger and i kill people
and he pulls he pulls out of his coat
a sheet of paper and he reads the home
address of paul corsetti the the make
and model of his car his wife's car
the license plates and then he then he
says
and here's where your daughter goes to
the day care center and he shows a
picture of the daughter
next day i still remember like it was
yesterday because i was working at the
herald at the time paul corsetti shows
up in the city room wearing a gun
and
he goes to the boston police and they
say there's nothing we can do we got him
for we got him for 50 murders
so he goes to he goes to larry baioni
the the number two guy in the mafia and
uh and and he sits down with him and
larry says what can i do for you and he
says he says i got a problem with uh
this guy whitey bulger and larry goes ah
i could help you with anybody else but
that whitey he's crazy
no kidding's crazy well they finally
they finally got it straightened out but
for five years after that nobody wrote
anything about it there's a there's a
there's a quote i use in my book i
actually have it on videotape
it chris lydon got it in 1979 from kevin
white
it was the mayor of boston
and uh kevin white was doing they were
doing the cutaways so sort of semi off
the record
but
what kevin said to chris lyden you said
you know the media won't go after the
tough ones like billy and he said you
know he said
if my brother threatened to kill you or
you thought he would you'd be nothing
but nice to me
this is the mayor of boston saying this
and then he said
the one time during busing he was over
in south boston at the athletic club and
he was afraid to come out at night
because he thought whitey was going to
kill him and as he said because whitey
was crazy enough even then
and he said if they you know if they
knock me out they're going to get an
anti-bussing guy named jerry o'leary who
later went to the can that's a recurring
theme in this book people going to the
can
and i don't mean the men's room either
and
that's that was again that was a large
degree to a large degree the source of
their power he
he he took
whitey was was mr
mr menace he was the shadow behind the
throne and you know i've told the story
a million times now but uh
jack hines
who i worked with the channel 56 the son
the former channel 5 anchor the uh the
son of the former mayor of boston
they had this liquor store that they
extorted and i've written about that in
the book as well the brothers bulger
and
the the liquor store was halfway between
the herald where i work in channel 56
where i used to work you know the globe
halfway between the herald and the globe
so i go by it every day or just about
every day whitey used to hang out there
it was the damnedest thing you ever saw
you know he'd be standing out there he
liked to do business there's a rotary
right at the liquor store it was a good
place to to
you know do bad things sneaky stuff
because they it didn't matter what kind
of bug they put on the the noise is too
much from the cars so they'd be hanging
out there and they'd see me going by
let's go
so guess what
didn't matter if i if i had a thirst so
great it would cast a shadow i wasn't
going in that liquor store
i was cutting across the andrew square
so they figured it out that i was never
going in the liquor store so they asked
jack hines one night he goes in and he's
and they say how come howie never comes
in here jack and jack kind of backs away
they say will you tell howie if he ever
comes in here
we got a dumpster waiting for him out
back
it'll be another robin benedict and she
of course was the combat zone prostitute
who got chopped up and they never found
any parts of her body after that i
started driving home a different way
every night
you know i i never never never hung out
as much at jj foley's anymore either
didn't want to get caught flat-footed
coming out of there one night around
midnight with uh two or three beers in
me
but
then later on they uh they decided the
white white was really paranoid about
about the press they
they also at one point whitey one of
whitey's minions was recorded to say boy
is whitey mad at howie now the other guy
says what did he do now
and he says well
you see the thing in boston magazine
where they said whitey was worth 50
million dollars how he wrote that
whitey says how he's setting himself
setting him up for a snatch by the
italians
they talk about paranoia
but they they also they did it to other
reporters as well you know there was a
guy at the globe
who was uh who used to work at the
herald got him kevin cullen and uh he
was working on the the the story in 1988
about the the connections between the
two brothers and they were the the fbi
at this point was concerned that they
were going to be embarrassed for obvious
reasons because there was so much to
embarrass them with
and uh so they sent a guy out to to talk
to they said the guy had to call cullen
who was one of the reporters and they
said
uh i just talked to uh i just talked to
this guy and he mentioned the name of
one of the one of the people who was in
the race fixing scandal from 10 years
earlier and he says this guy wanted me
to tell you that watch out what you do
with whitey because he's going to clip
you if you do anything
of course that was a beautiful a
beautiful sort of misdirection play
because the guy's in the witness
protection program
how do you go how do you confirm it
you can't confirm it
you just have to take the fbi agent's
word for it they tried to they did they
made the one call and then they never
called him again
1988 of course too was also the year
that uh that george bush was running for
president against mike dukakis
and and even though mike dukakis gave
billy bulger everything he wanted as
president of the state senate he still
didn't like mike dukakis going back to
the days of bussing
and he liked george bush because george
bush always called in to the st
patrick's day breakfast and came up with
some good jokes and all that sort of
thing and
so
19
july 1988
the democratic convention in atlanta
ends
remember it dukakis was ahead by 17
points
i don't know about you i was pretty
scared
[Laughter]
but
billy bulger according to members of the
bush family called
the vice president george h.w bush and
said
i think you want to come up to boston
and have a photo op on boston harbor
because you know governor dukakis is
always talking about how competent he is
and what a great
environmentalist he is but
the harbor's filthy
a federal judge had to order the cleanup
it's costing billions of dollars you
could really uh dust him up with it
and
george bush came to the harbor had a
great press conference pretty soon
dukakis's lead was evaporate had
evaporated and since then bush bush41
has has supposedly told people that
that's what turned the campaign around
and
i still i still don't think dukakis even
knows he must be the last guy in
massachusetts not to know what's
happened what happened to him because
whenever whenever they try to take away
billy bulger's pension he's always the
guy who writes the op-ed piece in the
boston globe
maybe i should send him a copy of the
book it's the only way i'll ever read it
i know he's not going to pay for it
but
one thing about the billy is i i know
that he has great ties to the to the to
the bush
republicans in addition of course to
being a nominal democrat and we we can
see that from the 2000 presidential
debates we all know that the most
important debate is the first one right
because that's the one everybody's
watching where was the first
presidential debate held in the in the
year 2000 it was held at uh at umass
boston when he was the president of
umass he he obviously had to tie in to
the bush family and he had to tie into
the democrats through ted kennedy who he
was even then negotiating with i suppose
to to get the to get ted kennedy's
papers
whatever that means for the uh for the
umass library but of course the the the
bloom was a little off the rose you know
that was it was billy's last great
victory i guess as a politician as
president of umass
but the bloom was a little off the rose
when the national reporters when they
looked out of the debate hall out onto
the harbor
they would see on on the beach
state police backhoes and they were
digging up the death pets where where
whitey had left all of his victims
i mean that that's just sort of the
whole
story encapsulated right there you know
just you know you have the highest
supposedly the highest and then the the
absolute lowest pits of the underworld
and it's this it's the same family and
it's it's within a hundred yards
of one another
but anyway i know there are a lot of
books to sign here and a lot of people
have a lot of questions so i'll just
i'll be glad to take some questions it's
really nice i appreciate the jabberwocky
for having me here tonight and uh and
it's great it's great to be in
newburyport even though i called it
amesbury and i
i know i i've got to work i've got to
work on my essex county geography i
understand that and when we go into the
trade paperback i'm going to make
salisbury new hampshire salisbury
massachusetts as it should be i'm very
embarrassed by that little error
[Applause]
okay any questions yes sir
um i believe everything you say about
whitey and what i've read about you
no doubt this guy was as ruthless as
they come
he had people killed
yes it will
since you were such a thorn in his head
rather than rather than threatening you
with that as i'm sure he didn't do with
many of the other victims
why
do you have any theory as to why he
didn't just have you knocked off
sometimes
why he didn't have me knocked off i well
i'm talking about years ago yeah no i
think
again if if i had made a mistake
in in south boston if i had been in the
wrong place at the wrong time and it had
been night and no one had been around if
i if i just stumbled into the into the
liquor store you know
totally loaded i mean they might have
put me in the dumpster but i wasn't
gonna i just wasn't going to make that
mistake and and they had they've gotten
so used to uh to having their own way
threatening guys like they got away with
threatening corsetti they got away with
threatening cullen they basically got
away with threatening me you know and
again
any of us
who were we going to call
were we going to call the fbi
he was he was paying off six guys
in the fbi
zip connelly didn't even cash his
paychecks
for months at a time he was getting so
much cash
was it who was i going to call the
boston police department what was the
first thing
when ray flynn became mayor in 1984
succeeding kevin white who was afraid
what was the what was the first favor
that billy bulger asked of ray flynn his
neighbor from south boston he wanted him
to appoint zip connolly as the police
commissioner of the city of boston
he wanted they wanted to put a gangster
i mean not not some you know guy who's
an associate but i mean basically a a
made member of the crew in as the as the
police chief of the city of boston so
they want to control the fbi and the
boston police department when i heard
ray said no i've always had a higher
respect for ray since then
yes
yes sir
well well again you know i've been there
from the beginning with the kevin week's
threats like i said his he has a close
relative and i'm not gonna i i don't
even wanna name the relative
because i i'm not gonna i won't throw
him under the bus kevin apparently
doesn't care about throwing his own
relative under the bus but he lived
around the corner from me that's that's
how he knew where i lived they didn't
need to do any uh sleuthing to find out
where i lived i mean the guy would just
tell him and kevin kevin weeks
he
has gone into court over and over again
as a defendant and as a witness against
guys like zip connelly
and and said that he had nothing to do
with the murders he said at one point
they asked him why didn't you try to
stop some of these murders and he said
because if i try if i say anything i'm
going into the hole next to the other
person
and
and now so now
now that he's not under oath he's saying
he's doing he's doing these he's going
to do a hit on me he's going to whack me
out
so when is he lying is he lying under
oath or is he lying in the book
it's got to be one or the other he can't
he can't have it both ways and
the silly stuff
i mean the basketball the exploding
basketball come on
death wish five anyone
there was the three stooges in 1938 they
they pretended to be professors and they
they got a and then the professors were
chasing him they got an exploding
basketball
i'll give you another one the
replacement killers did anyone ever see
the replacement killers
it's a crappy movie too
like all the other movies he apparently
watches but the the this killer is going
to shoot he's going to shoot a cop
coming out
of his house and he sees that the the
the cop has his son
with him and the son is actually
bouncing a basketball so it's like kevin
may have seen that one and then split
the story in two
i don't know i i just
again
believe me when when i thought whitey
was after me i was petrified i was
extremely concerned i i i took all kinds
of precautions but but this guy is uh i
don't know if it's going to make 60
minutes but i said this guy is uh is
robin to uh to whitey's batman he's uh
he's he's nothing to fear
i think whitey is in the united kingdom
yeah he has i'm pretty sure he hasn't
been in the united states since uh 1996.
the uh the fbi he is he uh fled in
december of 1994
and finally in uh mid 1996 after giving
him a nice i don't know 18 month head
start the fbi decided to interview his
former girlfriend to find out what his
alias was i mean that's when that's when
they should have gotten him was back in
1995 or 1996. actually the cop stopped
him local cops in mississippi and i
believe wyoming stopped him for traffic
violations when he was when he was
thomas baxter but since the fbi had
never bothered to find out that that was
his alias they didn't know they just let
him go
and so
yeah yes sir
i was wondering why did ed bradley do
such a puff piece on billy bulger now
you're on tv with him tomorrow night you
must have got to talk to him about that
while you were doing your
your interview but he treated it like uh
this guy wasn't one of the biggest
criminals in the state actually i got to
stay i got to stand up for ed bradley on
that was morley safer who did that puff
piece on on billy bulger
ed bradley did the piece on eddie
mckenzie the guy who claimed there was a
dog the dog room which there were there
were questions about that uh by the way
ed bradley
in uh in his youth he went to prep
school with uh
with johnny moderato for a year
down in rhode island and uh ed bradley
was an offensive lineman and uh johnny
madorano was the uh was the fullback and
ed braley told me they had a nickname
for uh for johnny they called him
the milkman
because he always delivered
a few years later he was delivering
something other than milk
but i you know the thing was it's it's
good for it's good for my book to be on
with with ed bradley on 60 minutes i i
you know i
i i would prefer not to give uh credence
to uh to weeks but you know what the
hell i i'll i'll go along it's good for
business
and
you know and the other thing about it
the other thing about ed bradley is he
has the he has sort of the proper
perspective on this he he's when we were
doing the cutaways during the during the
shooting
at the uh four seasons he said you know
he said
we're moving our way up the mob totem
pole so we started at the bottom
with eddie mckenzie we've moved the
smidgen up with kevin weeks said next
stop johnny moderato
yes up here yes
joe moakley was pretty big and salty how
did he escape all this corruption i'm
just curious about joe mobley joe
moakley was one of their neighbors you
know he was uh he was another guy who
came out of the the old colony housing
projects
and uh he he gave
joe billy always followed in joe
moakley's footsteps joe moakley gave up
his his seat in the house of
representatives in 1960
billy billy took the took the seat 1970
joe gives up his seat in the senate to
run again to run for mccormick's seat
when he when he run doesn't run and
billy succeeds him they were they were
always buddies you know i remember at
the when when moakley died the longtime
congressman from south boston who was
succeeded by steve lynch billy gave this
tearful interview on tv and said
i said you know in the worst of the
times you know meaning when they were
digging up the death pets and the worst
of the times joe sat down with me to
show that he wasn't deserting the family
so they they were they were buddies but
i mean he wasn't he wasn't
the corruption like
who were them um i mean if you owned a
convenience store or or a variety store
selfie you had the ball just collecting
at every store there
yeah yeah well i mean
yeah then well i used to you know
you know how tough they are if you've
got if anybody's got a got a liquor
license or no or has worked at a liquor
store you know how tough the state is on
you know they they really they really
enforce the rules fairly
fairly strictly but
when when they own that liquor store
they were selling to all the the bars
in the in the town in south boston right
out of the liquor store i mean that's
just a total violation of the law yes
sir howie great book would you comment
uh zip conley such a corrupt fbi agent
in morris and on and on in the book
would you comment on how many people are
falsely imprisoned in the boston area
and probably throughout the country it
just seems like the the fbi is the
political police department for the
politicians and is there a possible
follow-up book about that
well
i
i don't i don't know what i'm going to
do for a follow-up book but you're right
you're right about the fbi the the the
amazing thing about the boston fbi
office is that there there have been two
got two agents
indicted for on first degree murder
charges in
in
states as far away as oklahoma and
florida gang land hits
no the fb i've talked to people in new
york i've been on new york radio talk
shows and i say
have two agents in new york ever been
indicted for the for gang land hits and
they no the answer is no the the you
know the worst one of the bunch maybe
even worse than connolly was this guy h
paul rico
rico was a uh
was was the guy who uh
who was first first met whitey in in uh
when whitey was a male hustler in the in
the bay village in the early 1950s
and uh he was j edgar hoover put rico in
charge of uh bringing down the mafia and
jay edgar hoover put out this memo in
1961 and said he was under he taken a
lot of pressure from robert kennedy the
new attorney general to crack down on
lacoste nostra and he sent out a memo
and he said we're going to use the same
techniques we used against the american
communist party against the mafia which
of course we know what that means
anything goes you know forget you know
forget the bill of rights forget
anyone's constitutional protections just
go after them and get them and that's
really what led to all the abuse and
rico rico ended up
he had two guys hit
because they crossed him in the uh
in the irish gang wars of the sixties
then he was the one who ordered the the
hit on roger wheeler the guy who owned
world highlight in 1982 the ironic thing
is i'll take some more questions here i
always love this part of the book and
you know what it got it got cut out he
got left on the cutting room floor when
i was i i feel i'm gonna put it back in
if i get it to write a new edition
rico orders he's killed he's he's
ordered at least three possibly four or
five hits right he's a retired fbi agent
he's running this highlight company
remember elsie hastings
the he's now a congressman from florida
he was a corrupt federal judge he was
taken he was taking payoffs they said we
want to bring down alcie hastings we
need some fbi agent who can pretend to
be a mafia don
convincingly
paging h paul rico
so after the guy
just months after the guy has been
ordering organized crime hits he has to
pretend to be a dawn who organizes who
who orders organized crime hits any and
he brought down all c alcy hastings but
again
so he went from being on the federal
bench to being in the u.s congress
yes sir
how did rico last as long as he did i
mean
you know i don't i don't know about the
mafia but the fbi had a real good omerta
system going you know and it was
enforced it was enforced into the uh
into about
i got i got all the memos from the from
the uh the hearings you know when they
had the uh
the
the uh
pre-trial hearings in 1997 1998 about
these guys being fbi informants whitey
was an fbi informant quote unquote
but he they were basically giving giving
him information in return for money and
uh
the the amazing thing about the the hit
that actually led to the hearings
in washington that brought down billy
bulger that was the teddy deegan hit in
1965.
the fbi knew two days rico wrote a memo
to to j edgar hoover two days before
teddy deegan was killed saying they're
doing they're doing dry runs on the hit
and he named everybody who was
gonna kill him
the morning after the hit rico wrote
another memo to washington saying who
had done the murder
and yet three years later
rico let his one of his uh top
informants got the first guy in the
witness protection program joe barboza
lie
under oath
and send four innocent men to prison for
30 years
just to protect his informant
and that's that quote i play on the the
sound cut i play on the radio show all
the all the time when chris shays the
connecticut congressman says says to him
uh
how do you feel you framed four innocent
men you stood by and let them go to pr
you first you should have prevented the
murder because you knew it was going to
take place and then after the murder you
you let these guys
do 30 years
and of course h paul rico's response is
yeah what do you want for tears
yes sir
yes
there were a lot of uh fellow travelers
in the media at the time and
and one of the worst i think was mike
barnicle who whose career ended in
disgrace as you know
and uh at the boston globe and uh he
after after whitey won the um the mass
millions in southie he said that the
the only that he'd be giving the money
to uh to bombs
on the street in south boston and that
the only the only conversation whitey
and billy had was past the gravy on
sunday afternoons at the
at their house and then
when when johnny johnny moderato when he
finally flipped he knew a lot about uh
conley's crimes and so
as soon as as soon as it became clear
that johnny madorano was going to be a
real threat to
zip connolly's
freedom
barnacle wrote a column it turned out to
be the last column he ever wrote for the
globe and it was just the it was just
the most atrocious
nonsense he ever wrote in a 25 25-year
career of writing atrocious nonsense he
said he said that johnny madorano used
to use blacks for target practice
in roxbury
he said he said he killed three black
women in in one fell swoop in 1969 he
killed he killed one i mean i'm not
making excuses for johnny moderato he
was a serial killer too but this this
guy barnacle just made up the whole
thing to uh to to try to protect the
billy and whitey it was it was
disgraceful there were there were other
people at the globe who were who were
just as bad but let's not forget the
globe also was was the uh
the first newspaper to actually
try to point out the connection that
whitey would be an fbi informant so you
know i i can't i can't totally knock the
globe
but i can sure not mike barnicle
okay yeah yes sir when you were planning
the book did you ever think of maybe
going fiction and write a novel or was
all this just too unbelievable to
go non-vegetarian i think this is a case
where the the old saying applies truth
is stranger than fiction
yes
yeah that's a really good question
johnny monorano was a was a very gifted
athlete he uh he was an all-state
football player he uh he could have gone
to any college he wanted basically i
think what happened was this his father
owned the place in the combat zone and
he just sort of he grew up around those
guys